but before we come to harlem and see how
all this interaction happens we have to
kind of look at how Harlan became Harlem
and what brought these two groups
together and we're looking at the image
of the main central buildings to the
Columbia exposition and a Columbia
exposition opened in 1893 and if we
would all stay about Columbus Columbus
sailed the ocean blue in 1492 so they're
a year behind so been in 1893 you kind
of wonder why well they just like the
Olympics or anything it's like what city
is going to get this you know and why
not New York Chicago when well New York
was considered and it was the northern
end of Central Park it was going to be
and the southern end of Harlem over to
the Hudson River and they talked about
the beauty of the neighborhood and you
know it could be Manhattan's Acropolis a
place for the fair and it didn't happen
for the fair but it happened in terms of
development and really looking at this
place at the career would be a great
place to spur middle class and upper
little class development and so will you
see they did seize the Acropolis of
Manhattan where Columbia's today was the
bloomingdale asylum some people say the
use hasn't changed but you can see you
see the arts there for some sink to say
John the Divine the st. Luke's is next
to it there this is the bottom loop of
loan from Morningside Park and this
postcard is tourist postcard those steps
are still there that's walking up to a
hundred intensity so you can see the
elevated train that ran across 110th
Street if any of you know spoonbread the
restaurant the next time you're there
look at you see a series of load
buildings on that corner and you'll see
it's like a saw to for the Billings on
the next three that's because the train
turned that corner and they couldn't
build out to that to that corner by the
Train want up spread the development to
neighborhood and all the universities
you know Columbia Barnard st. john the
divine grants tomb they all start
seasoning these spots along the
Acropolis of Manhattan's great views of
over the plains of flats of Harlem but
also out to the Hudson River and it's
also part of the city beautiful movement
so if you negotiate in your East Harlem
or harlem you can look across certain
streets so 112 street and see Saint John
the Divine 120 first you can still see
little bits of grants to riverside
church and that's very unusual for the
grid because in Paris these cities are
laid out so you can see the particular
buildings and the grid it's open-ended
but in Harlem went under that see
beautiful moment they'd be like take a
pic spots along the drive that would be
on axis with the cross streets oh yeah
that's the kind of view you don't
typically see in other parts of the art
but the other side of the fair which
becomes the other side of harlem that
people don't really talk about is that
there was this amusement called the
Midway parlance and that was off of all
the high in a high and mighty that was
going on it was made to be almost like a
three-dimensional museum all these
different countries had had pavilions
and booths and these things that were
there to titillate so Zig fell was from
Chicago and he went to Europe and
brought routes and L the body builder
and someone else brought little Egypt
the whole term hoochie coochie and
everything comes out of the this but the
streets were made to look like Egypt or
made look at with some area of some
other part of the world some people who
hadn't traveled to that part of the
world have a chance to sample what it
might might be or that the time what
they thought that that might be it was
hugely popular and it was organized by a
man named Saul bloom who's in the music
business who comes loops to New York
after the fair as the congressman from
Harlem from the 1920s like 19 20 22
after the Second World War and he had
music publishing company and all that so
he
it is a musical person is looking at all
that this in the neighborhood as well
but one of the biggest attractions was
the home a village they brought actual
buildings from the homayon africa and a
tribe of africans who the reader their
dress there are musical instruments and
all sorts of activities around their
performance and chicago be no has very
horrible winters so when the winter came
the things that we're big attractions
moved to San Francisco and they had like
a winter fair of some of those
entertainment and the village got there
before the Africans and actually
Americans had to pretend to be Africans
for while Bert Williams and Williams of
Walker were one of them but they stayed
on when the Africans came and I believe
listen to their instruments and other
traditions in the in their music which
we'll talk about those you go forward
when I started doing my research the
interesting thing about this rags Harlem
rag and it was popular to fair wasn't
published to like 19 1894 but it's the
first publisher egg song by an
african-american and made me realize in
1890s why is Harlem associated with reg
must have a musical culture here already
this is way before the Harlem
Renaissance period after referencing
Harlem already is associating with black
music made me think that there might be
a community here musically as well
now Harlem is starting to have its own
Midway of its own this is 125th street
where those ladies are standing is the
plaza to the Harlem state office
building with the statue of a am clayton
powell is if we're looking west that's
the elevated train that we saw on the
other postcards it's the elevator ain't
going up eighth avenue and this early
hotel building has been replaced by the
teresa hotel was at that location on the
other side and this is even before the
fair this is 1890 and you can see ham
and and Harlan well that's a oscar
hammerstein the grandfather to oscar
mercy me know as a musician as the
composer so it's Hammerstein's harlem
opera house you still see a house on the
block so you can see how the
neighborhood slowly developing and it's
pushing entertainment it's and he's
looking at entertainment to the audience
that he's built in the Opera House for
and he's looking to compete with
downtown is looking to compete with the
Metropolitan Opera mr. hammerstine
wasn't not really a music person he just
loved opera and theater and he made a
fortune in tobacco processing and other
activities related to tobacco he had a
patent and other things allowing to
create a great fortune to build what he
was interested in it I opera was it and
this is a picture of Lily lerman who
was a opera singer she came to America
she's saying Norma in America eight
times and two of those eight times she
sang it on 125th street at his opera
house